this is a production of Cornell
University
yeah thanks everyone for for tuning in
again to the Cornell Turf Show this is
episode four season four
uh today we're gonna have a nice Lively
uh Lawn and Landscape conversation uh Dr
kale Bigelow uh is a professor of
horticulture at I don't know okay do I
want to say the university yet you had a
rough time in the NCAA tournament maybe
we'll just call it a university in
Indiana uh but we don't we don't want to
attract much more attention at an elite
Big Ten University at least 10
University
I picked him to win kale
know I picked them to win
sometimes sometimes things don't that's
why they play the games right so well we
won't talk too much more about sports
we're going to be talking a lot about
grass today yeah but I'll bring in my my
co-host as always Frank Rossi uh Frank
we're we're sort of getting to the the
growing season here maybe we're gonna
see a little pause here up in up in the
Northeast but uh interesting to see uh
what you're thinking of of the growing
season so far and and things you're
seeing uh seeing out there these days
okay
all right Carl you got me
yep you got me to see the slides all
right good ciao thanks for joining us
everybody thanks for listening thanks
for watching
um we're back at it uh the fastest 30
minutes uh it was actually one of the
highlights of this time of year we're
gonna have a little uh disruption I
think in the next couple of weeks in
some way shape or form because
everybody's life seems to be back to
normal Cal people are traveling it's
hard to get people around at this time
of day uh it was really easy when we
were all locked up right Carl but not so
much uh not so much uh anymore we're
sort of back at it now speaking of back
at it I got this picture from a student
in the Great Lakes School of Turfgrass
management the one we teach
um through the University of Minnesota
and Sam Bauer green keeper people uh
this guy uh is this is Fort Greene Park
in Brooklyn just about a a three blocks
from uh Greenwood Cemetery where I've
been doing some work and this is what
happens in urban Parks especially when
you let the four-legged ones there right
this is pretty standard for what happens
in these Parks Carl and you know I know
you've got something to say about the
value of these parks and you know the
different experience it would be if
maybe that wasn't dirt uh in the middle
of Brooklyn so I'll leave it to you from
there to set up the context for your
rant on ecosystem services today yeah so
so I don't know if I'll call this a rant
today Frank but really just sort of what
we're interested in these days
um this term ecosystem Services some
people may or may or may not have heard
about this but really very simply this
is the value we as humans get out of
ecosystems uh and this was a cool paper
from from folks here at Cornell Grant
Thompson was he when he was here Jenny
countifin and they sort of segment these
ecosystem Services out uh specifically
for turf grass so we can have
provisioning Services Turfgrass gives us
things like uh sod or or ground cover uh
we're just looking at an image of a lot
of bare dirt it would be much better if
we had some Turf covering that to reduce
soil erosion reduce sediment getting
into our water bodies speaking of water
bodies regulating Services Turf can sort
of regulate the water cycle it can
accept a lot of rain it can promote
infiltration as opposed to runoff it can
filter out a lot of pollutants right
that's sediment that's that's floating
around nutrients it can handle so that's
a that's a value we as humans get out of
turf and then cultural surface is really
sort of the traditional way we think
about valuation and turf the Great
American lawn Levittown the origin story
it looks really good there's certainly
value in that but there's also value in
these functioning for us kicking a ball
around having a picnic right playing
golf playing all these other sports
those are cultural services and then
supporting services things like soil
formation and nutrient cycling but what
I'm interested in what we're interested
in these days Frank is
is turf grass in urban areas so turf
grass is where people are uh you can see
a little image here for those watching a
fractional turf grass area in the United
States and it's centralized in
metropolitan areas maybe that's a little
bit counter-intuitive
um but there's a lot of turf where
people are almost nine out of ten people
now are living in urban areas in the
United States so that's it's pretty
important it is where people are we can
have some valuation there a specifically
in New York our Turfgrass survey from
2003 is pretty dated but said we had
about 11 of our land cover in New York
uh as turf grass so there's a lot of
turf it is where people are and it's
it's interesting for us to sort of look
at the value of that
um so when you look at some regulating
Services specifically the the storm
water and runoff component
um you know turf grass as a filter as
opposed to impermeable surface so if you
build a parking lot as opposed to having
a park or an athletic field you're going
to have to build all the pipes to handle
all that runoff right that water's got
to go somewhere we got to handle that we
got to maintain those pipes so there's
studies that have looked at this that
have tried to do that cost benefit
analysis they say hey these Urban green
spaces these Turfgrass areas they're
worth at the low estimate thirteen
hundred to eight thousand dollars per
acre per year and in that sort of storm
water control runoff control that's a
lot of a lot of money when you start
adding that up over you know 20 acre
Parks 150 acre golf courses right so
there's some value in there that maybe
we don't realize uh provisioning right
giving us other value uh home value
right for every dollar you invest in
your home landscape you get about a
dollar 35 back there's some Roi there
also if you live near an urban Green
Space that house that same house is
worth more than if you live further away
and then there's these other things that
are really hard to Value things like
when you live near a quality Urban Green
Space you have more improved physical
and mental health for for adolescents
and kids that's huge living near Urban
Green Space for moving stress social
cohesion all you know covet really sort
of magnified that value so we get a lot
of these things from Turfgrass uh but
maybe maybe here's why I ran today Frank
is is we have to manage these areas well
to extract that value right so here's a
great image from ignati Ava and the
Australian group looking at Urban Lawns
from the left side of the screen you see
all that ecosystem service value carbon
sequestration cooling of and mitigation
of the heat island effect regulating the
water cycle hey that's great we like
that
but on the left side we say hey if we
manage these areas poorly maybe we're
over using resources or under using
resources we can create ecosystem
disservices right if we've got a spar
sweetie lawn and we're kicking up dust
moan in the summer right there's air
pollution uh if we don't have if we're
over using fertilizers or pesticides
right there's chance of leakage out into
the water bodies right supporting
biodiversity if we put too much into the
system uh maybe we're sort of uh
creating a more homogeneous
um uh you know soil micro population and
that's maybe not good so really it
depends on how we manage these areas and
and we really have to be thoughtful to
to maximize this positive end of the
equation and and minimize the the
negative end
what do you think kale
I think it's all good stuff personally
you know I think the one uh the third
one down there regulating air quality uh
you've probably seen it I've certainly
seen it uh these robotic mowers right so
suddenly that thing that's on the right
hand side maybe is not as big an issue
you know in the future because I I
genuinely think that these robotic
mowers these electric mowers are gonna
uh certainly gonna provide some help
there and and and that's gonna reduce
some of those greenhouse gases so but
yeah yeah there's no no question about
that if you look at some of the things
on the on the right that are disservices
a few of them come from just burning
fuel uh to Mowing and that is the thing
Carl you're exactly right all the good
intentions to have Parks uh with grass
for people to use because it's
culturally a part of our society uh and
all we do is mow it it doesn't look so
good sometimes when we don't care for it
as much as we could all right I'm really
glad uh and now I just added one more
thing hardly any of that work is from
the United States I think some of the
valuation is Right some of the
stormwater value and some of the home
expenses are U.S data right Carl yes
they are the home expense stuff is is
what we care about that's exactly right
right we don't care about that we don't
care about the other ecosystem Services
anyway uh just an update on on you know
for the grounds and Lawn and Landscape
folks this is our uh every other week uh
last week we had some sports stuff with
Ben Palmer
um and this week we'll do just a general
walk through grounds uh Lawn and
Landscape stuff as we get going and as
you get going it's hard to not know that
the season has gotten going uh this is a
picture of uh Forsythia blooming in
Riverhead out on the Eastern end of Long
Island uh February 22nd this year so
this is a a really a profound effect but
also Carla manifestation a bit of
urbanization right you got a lot of
buildings even though Riverhead is a
little more rural there's still a fair
amount of pavement out there now look
looking at heat accumulation just draw
everybody's attention to the forecast
website the Turfgrass weather website
we've managed now since 2004. we've got
some changes to it some of the tables
along the top that used to be colors now
have behind normal uh and uh in this
case we're looking at Degree Days over
the last week we're about nine days
behind normal this week compared to last
year uh became I'm sorry compared to the
30-year average so we're a few days
behind normal you have a graph of it now
you can also look at the gray line on
the website and see what the forecast is
right so we're going to remain uh behind
moving forward very easy way to uh pay
attention to these Maps really work good
on the on the phone too we've set them
up really to work very good in that
adapted mode
um and so just a couple of things about
the natural world you might be observing
and what other models are telling us
this is uh Kevin Frank and the folks at
Michigan State the gdd the gdd tracker
um this is relative flowering times for
broadleaf weeds uh uh something we're
going to be talking about uh a little
bit today and moving forward you know as
we continue to be concerned about
maintaining that biodiversity which
includes some flowering plants
potentially uh in the lawn uh we've got
some early Season Winter annuals making
their way into the New York metropolitan
area and South so as you get to the
southern part of the region you're
starting to see those early winter
annuals already making getting close to
flowering uh which means they're too big
or too late for control uh depending on
how advanced they are and just a heads
up because we won't see you for a couple
of weeks you got a couple of weeks to
start worrying about crabgrass
germination especially that this week we
don't think we're moving very far and
Cal looks like this is already or made
its way out to you you're also not ready
for Crabgrass germination and usually
you're a little bit ahead of us uh
anyway so we have some maps on here for
broadleaf we control some of this
research I think actually happened at
Purdue many years ago when Riker and
thrassle were there this is the early
season 24d model for uh dandelion
control using either an amine or an
ester formulation and again you can see
we're not going anywhere you you don't
have to worry about getting a sprayer
out and doing spot spraying or anything
yet if you have to make applications in
the spring we all know this isn't the
preferred time to make those
applications but if you do at least a
little bit of data to guide you soils
are still pretty cool right we've
noticed this they were in the 50s a
couple weeks ago and now you know into
the 30s and 40s again here in the
Northeast low you know mid 40s at best
even in the metropolitan areas where
some heat Islands can occur uh some
other interesting things going on at the
forecast website the way we're depicting
some of the water uh rainfall events
that are happening we're building a lawn
watering tool calls building a long
watering tool to improve move our use of
irrigation have some maybe some
data-driven approaches to irrigating the
landscape in particular and you can see
you know we're expecting about we've had
about uh a half of an inch of rainfall
you can see where we are relative to
normal we were dry getting in the
springtime here particularly up where we
are and now it's getting a little bit
above normal but nowhere near the
moisture we were getting uh in in 2022.
so interesting to see uh very easy to
look at again looks really good on a
phone uh very easy to decipher when
you're trying to figure out rainfall
amounts
um and we're expecting normal temps
through the next week which is in the
30s and 40s so most people will not be
accumulating unless you're to the very
far south of the region uh a lot of
Growing Degree Days now there is a
disparity in the region there are I
think the southern part of the region is
much more advanced than we are north of
New York City so there's a real
demarcation there we heard from Richmond
yesterday that as soon as the rain falls
coming it's on things are growing things
are popping down in in Central and
certainly Southern New Jersey and Beyond
and we're expecting adequate rainfall
right so this won't be limiting in any
particular way so you know you can
expect things not to move very much but
also not to be limited by rainfall now
as we start to talk about grounds
management right large-scale grounds
management this probably could have been
done better uh maybe with an applicator
that uh you know actually dispersed the
material
um this is a you know a late season
fertilizer application from a hotel room
uh you know looking down on it so a very
interesting depiction of poor spring
fertilization I do I I do I do admire
the fact they went two directions though
I know
you have to admire that they did two
directions for those of you watching on
NewsChannel 10 here you could you could
see that checkered pattern callous
exactly right so I decided to ask the
machine pal what we should do about
spring fertilization seeing as though I
see if you and me and Carl are as smart
as the machine so I typed in the
question should I fertilize my lawn this
spring and the machine says the decision
to fertilize your lawn in the spring
depends on a few factors that's very
nice grass type climate condition of
your lawn so it's a good time it's a
good idea to fertilize your lawn in the
spring to encourage Healthy Growth help
it recover from Winter damage however
don't you know avoid over fertilizing
excessive growth may require frequent
mowing increased risk of disease hell
they're not going to need us anymore
brother we've done this already so so
now I don't know if I should fertilize
might be helpful have a soil test I I
don't know if I want to fertilize what
type of fertilizer
um but it's generally safe to fertilize
it in the spring just be sure to avoid
um not over fertilizing so I just before
I got I gotta I'm trying to set you up
here Cal so Carl and I mostly Carl have
been I've worked with the upper
Susquehanna and Shamong watersheds uh to
develop these Urban nutrient management
uh plan guidelines
um and we were acknowledged I just put
it up there Carl you got acknowledged
there in the uh publication and we've
decided to start to look at fertilizing
the land that's turf grass
um as high traffic
um generally just mature Turf uh that's
mostly low traffic and newly established
Turf and then within the first two types
we separated it out by salt type sand
based and and Native soils high traffic
or low traffic and we've given some
guidance on you know amounts allowed in
a single application some of this is
Guided by Marty's Marty's and Doug's uh
church and then a maximum annual amounts
uh here for the Watershed that we think
you'd ever use even on a sand based
system that receives some high traffic
right so we then said well how do you
know uh what you're doing here so and
how do you know how you should fertilize
based on your high traffic sand based
systems you have a high priority a
medium priority a low level of priority
what should you be paying attention to
what should you be doing relative to the
kind of turf you have again sand based
high traffic low traffic native soil and
then the the um differentiation for the
newly established tarp right your newly
establishing but it's a little you know
it's very medium level priority it's not
a big priority and then the big button
here at the bottom right Carl is the if
the turf's doing well uh don't fertilize
it and Dan Scheid here and I were Yak in
the other night over a beer and and you
know we've gone from three
fertilizations and you know two week
controls a year to one fertilizer and
one weed control uh a year so we've
already on the campus here begun to make
some big strides and and reducing this
Usage Now cow you presented this at the
at the international meeting uh on
Clover and and and you had this great
chart here I'm so I love preparing for
these conversations thanks for again
being willing to join us so you guys put
the Clover in and then monitored the uh
dry matter production uh from these
Lawns that you put the Clover into and
the graph we're looking at here uh
depicts what happens when you don't put
the Clover in
um you put the Clover in uh and and and
don't fertilize it and then you do those
same things and then fertilize it right
so I'd like to just stick with the you
know the don't fertilize because the 98
kilos is two pounds a year right so
that's within our range that we would do
but when you put clover in here kale
this must have been surprising for you
let's start a little bit at that
yeah so this was a study again you know
looking at nutrient management and this
idea of you know what could we
potentially do for you know particularly
utility areas you know that maybe are
are are prone to maybe not very high
density and somebody's interested in not
having to invest in you know synthetic
fertilizers and all those other kinds of
things and you know I think it's
important to mention you know this is
that micro Clover okay so this is this
is that more uh compact uh type of
clover a little bit smaller leaves a
little bit more attractive actually
mixed into the canopy
um in such a way that it wasn't
um it wasn't aesthetically unpleasing so
it worked out pretty cool
um but I think what's interesting about
this this story is we were asking the
question of okay if you have the micro
clover in there and you are fertilizing
and again legumes do fix nitrogen from
the atmosphere so it was this concept of
a self-feeding lawn was was what we were
chasing down is if you suddenly had say
a lawn care company or you yourself
started to add granular fertilizers
would that start to negate the effects
of the Clover over time and and as you
look at this graph uh you know the the
clover plus the nitrogen certainly uh
you can see that Top Line uh on the on
on the on the left I mean you got a lot
of growth there the other thing about
Clover is clover is a very I'm going to
use a very technical term here a really
juicy plant it's really juicy in the
sense that you know if you get a lot of
clippings those clippings there's just a
lot of water in there and you get a lot
of material on the surface so what we're
actually doing uh my graduate student at
Tom Gabe is I was like you know this is
not going to be fun but you're going to
do it is he would go out there he would
mow and then we would get his biomass
measurements he would dry those down and
then we actually would grind the
clippings and return them back to the
surface in order to make sure that we
were getting everything back into the
canopy but it wasn't a crazy amount of
plots but it was it was I really wanted
this data and I I think um obviously
it's a hit with you so that's yeah well
I can tell you thank you Cal I'm telling
you thanks for doing this and Carl I
know we got a nugget here from kale
today because we were just talking about
we have a growth model Carl's developed
and been working on we're going to
include it in somebody's digital tools
that we're developing here uh and and I
think that particular nugget is
interesting Now cal so so there's two
things one is it looks like the second
year was a real Amplified effect the
slope of the line is is more dramatic uh
was there something about the growing
season that forced it to Surge like that
um what do you think yeah that's that's
a good question I had to go back and
look a little bit
um you know there was a supplemental
irrigation system in place but it's not
like we were watering a lot okay okay it
was it was enough I I we wanted to make
sure we had an insurance policy in case
we had a dry year right uh there was a
little bit more rainfall that particular
year and so it is possible there could
have been some mineralization from the
leaf litter of the Clover in this
situation okay um so the other thing
that's interesting is that with no
fertilizer you're getting more biomass
production and you know one of the
things we talk about with as far as
weeds or the benefit of a good a Turf in
an urban landscape is 100 cover right
and you don't want crabgrass in
particular filling in you don't want a
lot of annual weeds filling in if I'm
getting some additional growth I wonder
if that's enough to keep out some other
weeds did you recall did you use pres on
this or was there any effect of this
actually keeping the weeds at Bay
so there were a few situations
um again we minimized the pesticides
here uh as far as you know having to
deal with some of those things the site
didn't have a strong history of
crabgrass so that wasn't a big deal
um you know that the Clover that was
there you know over time like the third
year
um I think if you were to make this work
is you would still need to do some uh
interceding or overseeing of the Clover
because there were times that it it
started to become a little bit patchy
okay Frank I think the other thing
that's interesting is the second line
there yeah if we were to get crazy and
look at you know the actual slopes of
those lines uh the the the grass Clover
no nitrogen lines actually look like
they're fairly similar in terms of their
their sort of slow and steady growth
over the period of the uh of the study
but yeah but to your point where you're
putting in the nitrogen that really Jack
things up and and again that would
result in excess mowing so so I think
our our moves towards these sustainable
Lawns from a nutritional standpoint if
people are willing to you know think
outside the box there there's some
potential there yeah perfect okay so
um the other thing the machine said was
that grass type mattered and so I got
another I know you're an expert in tall
fescue so I want to take up tall fescue
you know these are Doug's uh sold that's
famous plots from a number of years ago
where he looked at planting them and
then looking at different fertilizer
amounts and I use this to get a lot of
tall fescue planted in New York even
when I first got here the improvements
in the tall fescues particularly As you
move North Cal are a big deal now where
you are they're the standard right
they'll they'll do as well uh as
anything down there I think won't they
uh particularly on these new subdivision
soils right and so that's that's where I
get a little bit you know these newer
subdivisions where you know they're
coming in and they're just they're just
packing houses in and they're scraping
soil off is you know when I talk about
Kentucky Bluegrass and you look at the
textbook definition it prefers moist
fertile well-drained soils right and and
that's great coming from the side Farms
out what used to be a corn farm here in
the Corn Belt but when you put it on
these new like scraped soils they
struggle I mean this sod and the
Bluegrass has struggle but the tall
fescues are more tolerant yeah yeah and
you still yeah yeah for sure so listen
this is our toe fescos Fescue story this
is a courtyard that was built here at
the school of industrial Labor Relations
at Cornell University
um and it actually was built in a way
that uh created allowed it to be two
zones warmer so this little Courtyard
was Mo plants that are in their
landscape plants that are in there
actually are plants that will grow and
Thrive only as far north as DC so we
have a really nice uh experiment here in
the middle so we you know we did what
exactly what you said they scraped it
off and then they mixed in some compost
right look at that look at the method of
soil uh that they created here uh but
the landscape plants get treated like
gold the grass not so much So eventually
we got a beautiful Turf type tall fescue
uh sod a 90 tall fescue 10 Kentucky
Bluegrass uh sod that one of our alum
provided and you can see when you got it
in there and that landscape is happening
it's it's just as good as it gets right
so let's look at it after uh the first
winter Cal
a lot of snow mold came in I think uh we
found out how much Bluegrass we had
because the tall fescue uh added a gate
struggled a little bit but so did the
Bluegrass so did some of the Bluegrass
in this particular year but because of
where this was at it started to really
we didn't do anything this is just
recovery within a month or so I see I
picked up your I I had this habit a
while ago I wish I would have put the
dates on it when I did it but we're
talking about a month's time here and
then June comes and we have the tents
and the chairs for graduation and you
can see it's by the Fall it's it's doing
pretty good and you know it actually has
been doing really well now uh year on
year now congratulations my friend and
receiving the Daniels award this is
great news congratulations that you got
from the sports Fields Managers
Association at their recent conference
in in January out in Salt Lake City and
so for all the young people listening
who don't know Bill Daniels I knew Bill
Daniels uh when he was at Purdue because
I was a kid and he spoke at conferences
uh I used to go to and Bill was the
original uh developer developer of the
per WIC system right the purwick system
yeah the perwick system that's an
interesting one but the Pat the PAT
system on the stadium Fields is a little
more successful that's right but the but
the perwick led to the pack right the
program the precursor to the pat SoCal
this is great recognition of your
wonderful career and you celebrate it by
tweeting out things like Billy moles
right yeah that's not me that's not me
that that that's a relocation program
there there's no there's no death
involved here Frank as far as you know
have you uh this is very interesting and
you know I have a couple of you know a
couple of simple questions but what
about moles um do have you had a worse
problem have you seen a worse problem
have you heard about problems maybe
because it was a milder winter
um you know we we consistently at our
turf research facility have some just
some locations that historically seem to
have populations that like to come back
and so we have some staff folks that you
know sort certainly monitor these and uh
uh you know we have a fence around our
research facility to try and protect the
turf so occasionally you need to
relocate some things uh that maybe are
not in alignment with the uh the mission
of the facility okay
relocate them with us with a spear well
I I you know I can either confirm nor
deny okay so okay you took these great
pictures right of the Purdue uh main
campus um this was in January or in the
50s January
February 9th you were at 26. uh February
26th you can see the frost and this was
just recently yeah that was the last
time so as I so you know we got a couple
of minutes for questions I asked the
machine about a limerick for you uh
please give me a limerick about kale
Bigelow let's do and it says Purdue
there's a professor named kale whose
expertise in Turf is beyond the pale he
studies grasses Galore from Fairways to
lawn Decor Cal bigelows the turf expert
without fail
cam wow I am honored I am honest so
listen you're not done yet how do you
like tall fescue what are the
limitations for many years uh in your
experience of having tall fescue what
are the things you tell people you know
transitioning now that you're seeing it
more in these places what do you
noticing
um if there are any limitations it might
be spring color right I mean you know
particularly in our environment and
maybe a little bit in yours you know we
do get those Winter desiccating Winds
and you get sort of that that little bit
of leaf tip you want I don't know if you
want to call it wind burn or whatever
and and it's a little bit you know slow
to kind of come out of that
um the other limitations maybe are you
know the leaf texture used to be a big
thing but but uh you know I've got a
grad student right now PhD student and
she's done some some pretty detailed
measurements with Leaf width on some of
these things and they're highly
compatible with the Kentucky bluegrasses
um the only other thing you know in
certain situations you could get a
little clumpy right you know it is a
bunch type grass so I think that is you
know mixing something like a Kentucky
Bluegrass at a certain amount is is
probably appropriate routine overseeding
routine overseeding as a as a practice
yes and then you know the the bigger
issue but you know we've got some really
strong genetics now you know our
breeding friends have done some really
you know really great strides in terms
of brown patch resistance that's right
but this has happened you know if you
talk to our friends in North Carolina
there's a little bit of the concern on
the gray leaf spray leaf spot you're
exactly Melody Fraser and Jim Kearns
down in North Carolina they've they've
increasingly seen some of the gray leaf
spots sneaking into some plots and you
know that's that's a hit or miss that's
that's a lottery card right right it is
now uh you know ever since Buckley
cursed us and said he never saw gray
leaf spot on tall fescue and he did it
in the you know in our conference call
Carl other questions yes we got a good
one about about the turf type tall
fescue so rich said he had a thrift
tough rescue blend with microcover micro
Clover he had it yep surrogated site sad
yep irrigated sight and non-irrigated
site he said the irrigated site got
hammered with white clover and the
non-irrigated site was was fine and he's
wondering why would we see that uh the
white clover moving in on the irrigated
site as opposed to the non-irrigated
site
I honest I mean I don't know that's
tough I just don't know but you know
Frank you've seen that you've seen this
before in a dry sight like a super dry
crispy kind of thing the clover will be
like some of the greenest stuff sitting
out there in the middle of summer you
know you'll see the big patch of clover
or everything else around it's kind of
off color and brown and this Clover is
just like so it Clover's more drop
tolerant than I think we give it credit
for I I agree 100 it's certainly if
nothing else certainly Spurs flowering
so Carl I'm trying to read this question
here they use Black Beauty micro Clover
sod one with irrigation the one
irrigated had the so they put it in two
places uh irrigation had more Clover no
irrigation was it says it was fine
I'm assuming fine means there was no
Clover and I guess my question is why
did you buy clovered socks I think he's
making the distinction between white
clover and and the micro clover in there
maybe oh
oh question then
what and we're called we're past the
time but this is a good one I have a
hard time differentiating it do you
really believe their separate species or
do you think the micro Clover is simply
an adaptation to more close frequent
mowing
um the micro Clover is genetically
different I mean they're they're still
same genus species just like the three
of us are the same gene species right
but we all look different right I mean
none of us can none of us can grow
Carl's beard right I mean that's I mean
look at look at that thing uh so so so
so we look we look similar but different
um and the micro Clover definitely does
not grow as tall and the leaves are
probably at least half the size I wonder
if you Juiced it though or you had water
on it and it was a really fertile sod if
maybe it got more plump and juicy to use
your brown pads any brown patch got in
there and and then thinned it out a
little bit I don't know but the white
clover itself he says thrived which you
know that's again to make sure there's
separating two uh separate species
because you know in the mark Marketplace
you do see just white clover being sold
you don't always see micro Clover so
that's a really important distinction
Carl
we can't be as fast as 30 minutes
and be four minutes over so Cal thank
you very much for taking the time I hope
you I hope you enjoyed spending this
time and yeah you me Carl and the
Machine uh telling us what to do
excellent excellent limericks from the
machine today we're gonna have to do
that for every guest from now on thanks
everyone for joining us hey Rich send me
some more information about this uh
please say because this is interesting
yeah um but thanks everybody
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell.edu